again I don't think we should see as  extremes because marriage is not an  extreme that marriage is based on  compromise so in terms of the Modern  Woman as  again I would say the modern women's and  it is an extreme but you know agree no I  think it's very common I think that I  mean the average age of first marriage  in the UK is 31. I mean in terms of  mindset like in terms of mindset I would  say anyone that waits till 31 to get  married has the Modern Woman mindset in  some in some regard and they're getting  older they have somewhere a lot of the  older women now are looking back and  thinking I could be a modern woman at 40  and 45 it's too late for them